To me.
I have four.
We'll talk about it.
Three.
Yes.
And we're live.
Hello.
Hey Joe,
welcome.
Thank you.
Oh,
that's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
Sam Harris sends his regards.
Yeah.
Sam's a beautiful man.
He is.
I love that guy.
And he's one of the reasons why you're here.
Um,
so universal basic income.
This is what this is all about.
Yes,
that's what my campaign for president is all about.
That's uh,
an interesting,
like a focus of a campaign and very unusual.
And I mean four years ago you'd never even thought that that would have a chance
at all.
But this is a subject that has been gained momentum and it made it,
I made a big shift because a,
I had my friend Eddie Wong on once and he was the first person to bring it up
and my initial knee jerk reaction was get the fuck out of here.
Like universal basic income,
just getting to give people money that just going to be lazy.
Nothing's ever going to get done.
That's a terrible idea.
And then I started paying attention to the rise of AI.
And automation and how many jobs are going to get taken away.
And then once you see the actual numbers,
it's pretty staggering.
Yeah,
and that's how I got there,
Joe.
Like I spent the last seven years running an organization that I had started
called venture for America,
and we helped create about 3000 jobs in Detroit,
Cleveland,
Saint Louis,
Birmingham,
New Orleans,
other cities around the country.
And I saw that were pouring water into a bathtub that has a giant hole of ripped
in the bottom,
and that for every five,
10 50 jobs that my entrepreneurs are going to create,
we're going to lose five 10 50,000 jobs.
It's not something that people intuitively suspect could be a real issue either.
It's one of the ones where you kind of have to like go shake people like,
hey,
look at this.
This is coming.
There's a cliff.
We're going towards this cliff.
It's darker still.
And that,
so when I was digging into the numbers,
I found that it's not this cliff that we're heading towards.
It's actually more of a curve that we're on or what I've been telling people is
that we're in the third inning now where one of the main reasons why Donald
Trump won in 2016 is that we automated away 4 million manufacturing jobs that
were based in Michigan,
Pennsylvania,
Ohio,
Wisconsin,
Missouri,
Iowa,
all the swing states he needed to win in the center of the country.
And a lot of that was just manufacturing work.
And if you go to a factory,
you'll see it's this giant robot arms as far as the eye can see.
So it's not just that you have artificial intelligence on the horizon,
it's that we've been eating away at the most common jobs in the u s economy,
uh,
for almost 20 years now.
And it's just now hitting a point where it's pushing more and more unskilled men
in particular out of the workforce.
Now.
Are there other alternatives that you've considered other than just universal
basic income,
like educating people about this being a real issue and perhaps pushing them or
directing them towards other occupations?
Yeah,
so that that's the uh,
recipe that people are attracted
to.
So I just want to unpack the numbers a little bit more so people have a sense of
it.
I was just with a bunch of truck drivers in Iowa last week and there's a Guy
Dennis,
but gasky that gave me a ride from Altoona at Grinnell in Iowa where I had been
campaigning.
And the truth of it,
Joe,
is that there are three and a half million truck drivers in this country right
now is the most common job in 29 states.
And the average trucker is a 49 year old guy with a high school education,
maybe ex military,
like Dennis was a,
they're making like $50,000 a year.
So then if you say,
Hey,
I'm going to retrain half a million truck drivers for what exactly is like issue
number one.
And then these guys didn't love school 30 years ago.
It's not like driving a truck has made them really excited about the idea and
then the new job you're training them.
Before I looked into the data as to how good we were at retraining.
Let's say displaced manufacturing workers in the Midwest when we started
decimating their jobs and we're terrible at like according to independent
studies,
government funded retraining programs had a success rate of between zero and 15%
in real life.
Like this is what actually happened to the workers of Michigan and Indiana and
Ohio.
And so if you say we're going to retrain these people,
then you also have to come up with a way for us to become amazing at something
that right now we're really,
really bad at.
And if you were an employer,
which you are,
would you rather employ a 50 year old former truck driver with health problems
who got some certificate program?
What would you rather higher a 25 year old kid who went to community college is
probably cheaper,
has lower expectations and his skills are natively going to be a little fresher.
I mean,
if you were an employer,
you'd probably choose number two.
I agree.
Um,
but I,
I'm,
I mean I'm trying to look at this through rose colored glasses,
I guess.
Awesome.
Thank you.
If there's a way that these people can adapt,
you know what I mean?
Some will for sure you can retrain and rescale some people,
but if you look at even the conversations we're having around this where people
legitimately talking about retraining coal miners to be software engineers,
stuff that on the face of it makes no sense.
But the reason why we're stretching for that is because we're looking for some
kind of retraining oriented solution when the numbers show that that's just not
going to be the recipe.
Therefore actual sex
SAS,
and this is where,
where this whole learn to code controversies coming out online where people are
actually getting banned for riding,
learn to code.
It's a really a hot subject on Twitter and it's very confusing too.
And I haven't really gotten an explanation for why that's such an offensive
thing to say,
but people are getting banned for economists.
This I know joking around saying learn to code and it's very weird.
But the idea behind it is that it's kind of preposterous to ask someone who
doesn't have an education to do something that's as difficult as code computer
language.
Yeah.
And unfortunately we're going to get to a point where AI can do some basic
coding at a certain level.
So if you think about the impulse to say,
learn to code,
what it's really saying is you need to do something that the market values,
it's like,
Hey,
being a truck driver,
the market's not going to value that much when the trucks are driving themselves
in the next five to 10 years.
So what does the market value?
And then people are like,
well,
coding and stem and,
and uh,
engineering skills.
And so there's a drive to try and push people in those directions.
But if you look at the numbers,
uh,
about 8% of American jobs right now are in stem fields,
like in technology,
engineering,
math,
etc. So you're talking about 92% of the population that is not in those fields.
And it's unrealistic to expect that 92% to somehow shift into the 8% right in
there,
even be places for them.
Yeah,
that's true too.
Even if they perfectly seamlessly transition,
there's too many people for those jobs.
Yeah.
So I've been driven to universal basic income in part because I've been looking
at the numbers.
The five most common jobs in the United States right now are administrative and
clerical work,
retail and sales,
food service and food prep,
truck driving and transportation and manufacturing.
Those five jobs comprise about half of all American jobs.
Only 32% of Americans graduate from college.
So the average is a high school grad doing one of these five jobs.
And if you look at it,
technology is already doing a number on each of these jobs.
Like the first administrative and clerical includes call center workers.
And Ai is in the process of taking over that job.
Retail and sales,
30% of malls are closing in the next four years.
So the,
the danger here is to think of it as artificial intelligence is coming.
It's actually already eating up the most common jobs in our economy and it's
driving Americans into distress in various ways in the numbers.
Now when you talking about universal basic income too,
there's two questions that come up.
How much money and where's it coming from?
Yeah.
So first I want to say that if you look at the heritage of universal basic
income,
it's a deeply American idea where Thomas Paine was forward at the founding of
the country and then Martin Luther King was for it.
Milton Friedman,
the godfather of conservative economist was for it.
And one state has had it in effect for 37 years,
where everyone in that state gets between one and $2,000 a year,
no questions asked.
And this is Alaska,
Alaska,
and they funded with a oil money.
And what I'm going around telling people is that technology is the oil of the
21st century.
So I know you spoke to another guest about,
hey,
how do you get,
let's say approximately $3 trillion a year to fund universal basic income?
And a great thing is that it's,
well,
the first thing is that it's not actually 3 trillion.
And the reason why it's not 3 trillion is that if you look at what we're
currently doing,
we have a,
we're spending about one point 5 trillion right now on 126 welfare programs and
social security.
And so if you show up to someone's door and say,
hey,
here's a dividend of $1,000 a month,
but if you're already getting more than a thousand and stuff,
we're not just going to stack it on top.
Uh,
you know,
we're going,
just going to say you're guaranteed a thousand.
And if you're already getting more than this doesn't touch you,
you can keep your current stuff.
If you're getting 700 and food stamps and whatnot,
then you can just get 300 on top.
So the 3 trillion actually shrinks a lot very fast because of the fact that
about half of Americans are already getting various,
uh,
income support from the government.
So the real price tag is closer to about one point 8 trillion.
If you say everyone who's 18 and up now for context,
the entire US economy is now 20 trillion,
5 trillion in the last 12 years,
and the federal budgets 4 trillion.
So you're looking at one point 8 trillion.
It's a lot of money.
Uh,
but it's actually manageable.
And one of the things that I haven't heard discussed here with you is that when
you put money into people's hands,
the money doesn't disappear.
Like if I gave you 1000 bucks a month,
it probably would not make a big difference in the economy because they're just
go into your account somewhere and you know nothing would happen.
But we all know that right now most Americans are living paycheck to paycheck.
57% of Americans can't afford an unexpected $500 bill.
So you put $1,000 a month and then their hands,
it's going to go right back into the economy.
They're going to spend it on food,
childcare,
car repairs have been putting off the occasional night out,
and then all of those businesses end up hiring more people.
And then we ended up getting some of the money back as tax revenues.
So of the one point 8 trillion we're going to get back,
let's call it 400 billion in new tax receipts because everyone's going to be
spending more money.
We're going to save one to 200 billion on things like incarceration and
homelessness services and emergency room healthcare.
I was in New Hampshire last month and a prison guard said to me,
there's a prison guard.
He said,
we should pay people to stay out of jail because we waste so much money when
they're in jail.
Like he sees all the waste in the system.
So if you imagine a society where everyone's getting a thousand bucks a month,
that's like a,
it's a great incentive to try and stay out of jail because you know,
you stopped getting it if you wind up in jail,
uh,
and it reduces recidivism because when you come out of jail,
at least you have,
you know,
1000 bucks a month waiting for you and then you're less inclined to,
to commit a crime and head back in.
How much crime do you think you would actually prevent though,
by giving people $1,000 a month?
Let me think.
Most of the people that are doing crime,
whether it's thieve,
thievery or assault,
they're not thinking this out.
You know,
this is,
this is just either a way of life for them either,
you know,
they're,
they've got real mental issues or a pattern of behavior that they can't break.
I'm really don't think that $1,000 a month it's going to fix any of that.
How's that going to fix all of it?
For sure.
I mean,
we'll still have jails.
It's not like,
you know,
silver bullet,
but at the margins would it keep like that person who's falling through the
cracks and feels like they have no place society and maybe they,
you know,
it's like the people around them are also like,
hey,
you know,
you don't have any value and then you get 1000 bucks a month maybe.
Like it keeps them off at the margins and everything we're talking about is at
the margins.
I mean,
everything's like this statistical curve and you're taking the people who are,
let's call it like the last 10 to 20% but if you reduce our incarcerated
population by 10 to 20%,
I mean that's billions and billions of dollars.
So you,
you're saving money on a bunch of things.
We spend about a trillion dollars on right now,
like healthcare,
incarceration,
homelessness services,
and then the,
the magic is that if you have 1000 bucks a month and you're a parent,
so you feel this,
that studies have shown that your kids are healthier,
better nourished,
more likely to graduate from high school and get further education.
Mental health improves,
uh,
relationships improve.
Domestic violence goes down,
hospital visits go down and your worker productivity goes up.
Mean you're an entrepreneur and CEO.
So,
you know,
when you run a company,
you say,
I'm going to invest in my people.
I'm going to like treat them well and try and train them and give them resources
because you know,
that'll increase your productivity as an organization.
In the public sector,
we have the opposite approach where like,
if I can just avoid spending money on you that you know,
I'm going to somehow save money when we end up spending that money and very,
very dark,
costly,
counterproductive ways in the backend because they wind up,
you know,
uh,
in our institutions and our institutions just spend a,
a truck load of money.
So if you look at the cost savings and the value gains and the economic growth
that actually gets you back about a trillion dollars or the 1.8 this is like the
trickle up economy because none of the money disappears.
It goes right back into the economy.
And the way you get the last 800 billion or so is related to what we think is
happening with AI and all these advanced technologies.
Because if you look at who's going to win with AI and self driving cars and
trucks,
that the savings from robot trucks are estimated to be $168 billion a year just
from that one thing.
So the problem is that the American public is going to see very little of that
money,
uh,
because the winners are going to be the trillion dollar tech companies that are
great.
It just not paying a lot of taxes.
They'll move it through Ireland.
Amazon will say it didn't make any money this quarter.
No reason to pay taxes.
And so what we need to do is we need to put in a new tax that actually gets the
American public a slice of every robot,
truck mile,
Amazon transaction,
Facebook ad,
and every other industrialized country already has this tax.
It's called a value added tax.
And because our economy is so vast,
at 20 trillion of value added tax,
that even half the European level generates about 800 billion in new revenue and
that gets you all the way there.
So this is much more achievable and affordable than most people think when they
start unpacking how the numbers workout.
So essentially it would be the biggest corporations,
the the companies that gain or that have the largest revenue,
they're going to be paying most of this.
Yeah,
but they're going to get some of that money back,
obviously,
because one of the things I say to the CEOs,
it's like if everyone in Missouri is getting 1000 bucks,
you know,
Amazon's going to see some of that because they're just going to buy more stuff.
That's true for all of the big companies.
What I say to CEOs,
and I've spoken to groups of dozens of CEOs.
What's really bad for your businesses when people don't have money to spend?
What,
what's good for your businesses when they do.
So they're gonna give up some money at the top end,
but then there's going to end up getting it back,
uh,
when their consumers end up spending a bit more been actually fleshed out.
Like the real numbers are the projections of how much they're going to get back.
Yeah.
Like the,
so the Roosevelt Institute study this plan of everyone getting 1000 bucks a
month and projected it would create 2 million new jobs,
uh,
and grow the economy by eight to 10%.
And then you can model out what that means to each business.
Because in that climate they're going to see a similar uptick in revenues.
Did they factor in all the jobs that are going to be lost?
So one of the things that's a misconception about universal basic income is that
a,
it's somehow we'll like facilitate job loss.
Job losses though,
is the reason for universal basic income in the first place,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Which way?
In the midst of right now,
like right now,
as we're sitting here together,
the labor force participation rate in the United States is 63%,
which is the same levels as El Salvador in the Dominican Republic.
That's right now,
like,
uh,
94 million or so Americans have left the workforce over the last number of
years.
Now,
a lot of that's natural demographics,
a lot of that people in school,
but about 5 million of it is unskilled men who've gotten pushed out in the
workforce.
So,
uh,
so again,
this is not like a,
you know,
we're going to solve a problem that's coming down the pike.
Like we're actually in the middle of this problem.
So if you put 1000 bucks a month into people's hands,
it actually grows the economy and creates jobs,
uh,
because of more economic activity.
Now,
when you say a problem that's coming down the pike,
what,
what are the projections in terms of like the timeline?
Yes.
So,
uh,
there are a lot of,
the projections are actually pretty consistent with each other,
which means they're probably right.
So the,
uh,
so banes says you're looking at,
between 20 and 30% of jobs subject to automation by 2030,
which is pretty soon.
It's like 11 years from now.
Mckinsey says about 25%.
Uh,
the Obama White House,
literally I think their last day in office they issued a report saying,
hey guys,
we're going to automate away all the jobs and then like,
you know,
turn the lights off.
Um,
they said 83% of jobs that make less than $20 an hour will be subject to
automation by 2030.
Mit is saying the same thing.
Uh,
and so we have 11 years to try and accelerate meaningful solutions and this 11
years,
it's not like it all happens on 20.
It's going to happen between now and then progressively according to all of the
major institutions that have looked at this.
Now when you take a guy who's working as a truck driver and he's making $50,000
a year and you tell him that automation is going to take away his job,
but good news,
we're going to give you $12,000 a year.
That's a substantial loss in income and it leaves them in.
Yeah.
It also leaves them with his feeling of uselessness or hopelessness that they're
not contributing.
You know,
I think one of the things that people enjoy is a earning their own way.
they,
people don't,
it sounds counterintuitive.
People don't like free money.
They'd like a feeling of satisfaction of a job.
Well done that they've created something that they've done something right.
Yeah.
You're 100% right.
It's one reason why we call this the freedom dividend.
We say,
look,
it's not money for nothing.
You're an owner and chair holder of the richest country in the history of the
world.
Just like when I buy Verizon or Microsoft,
they send me a dividend.
Like I don't complain about that.
Like your now a shareholder in this great nation and you get a dividend.
But when I was with Dennis,
the trucker who owns his own trucking company in Iowa,
uh,
the,
the role that job's playing in trucker is lives is vital.
And again,
I'm a very data driven guy where men deal with joblessness is very,
very poorly.
By the numbers we spend between 40 and 75% of our time on the computer playing
video games or doing other things.
Uh,
we are substance abuse goes up,
are volunteering in the community,
goes down,
even though we have more time and we generally spiral into antisocial and self
destructive behaviors.
Now this is not something that's uh,
experienced by women in the same levels like women and joblessness.
Women actually a more adaptable,
they're more likely to go back to school and volunteer.
They don't spend all their time on the computer is the way that we do.
So there's a real problem.
Uh,
and the purpose of universal basic income is not meant to be a job replacement
for those truckers because right now those truckers,
and when I talked to the truck drivers,
so I've been campaigning for president now for a number of months.
So I spent a lot of time in Iowa,
which is a really huge trucking hub.
And you go to them and say,
hey guys,
you worried about robot trucks taking your jobs?
They're like,
there's no way a robot could take my job like that.
That's,
you know,
that's like totally matter of fact,
they're like,
this is not something that they worry about.
Their attitude has transitioned from that somewhat too.
Uh,
we should make robot trucks illegal or we should make it so that a robot truck
cannot displace me.
So that's been a big shift because a year ago they were like,
it's impossible.
The idea that an American would say we should make a robot job illegal.
Like it's,
we should have some laws that keep you from being free to use robots for your
business instead of person.
Like you should be forced to highly mandatory unionization or something.
That sounds pretty ridiculous.
Well,
that's where a lot of the Marjoe uh,
so only 13% of truckers are unionized.
So 87% are like Dennis where there are small independent firms.
And a lot of them actually,
uh,
bought or leased their own trucks.
Uh,
so they took out tens of thousands of dollars in the equivalent of a mortgage to
get this truck.
And so if they have to compete against a robot truck,
that doesn't stop,
that's like,
you know,
that's existential level stuff.
And right now truck drivers have time use regulations where they cannot drive
more than 14 hours a day.
Uh,
so you can't,
you literally cannot compete because the robot trucks just going to keep going.
Our 15,
16,
17 et cetera.
So these guys make,
some of them make really good money.
Like some of them make 70,
75 $80,000.
It's one of the higher paying jobs for,
uh,
men without a college degree.
And so if you look at what they're facing,
it's not so crazy that they're like,
hey,
you need to make the robots illegal because for them,
what is the next best economic alternative if the robot trucks take over that
job?
Like what sound go for it.
Yeah.
It's not crazy for them,
but it's a crazy idea to tell a company that they can't do something that's more
efficient,
safer,
and probably economically more viable.
Oh yeah.
Again,
the savings from automating truck driving are estimated to be $168 billion per
year.
And not just labor savings but also equipment utilization because the trucks
never stop fuel efficiency because the trucks can daisy chain together.
So there's less wind resistance you accidents cause right now truck accidents
kill about 4,000 people a year so you'd probably save lives.
There's a very,
very powerful argument for the fact that we should be trying to automate this
stuff.
But on the other side you have literally three and a half million truckers who
rely upon this for their livelihoods to support their family and there's going
to be a lot of passion,
a lot of resistance to this.
Anyone who thinks the truck drivers are just going to shrug and be like,
all right,
I guess I had a good run.
I'm just going to go home and figure it out.
That's not going to be their response.
Right.
It's going to be much more likely that they say you need to make these robot
trucks illegal or they're just going to park their trucks across the highway,
get their guns out.
Cause a lot of these guys are ex military and just be like,
Hey,
like I'm not moving my truck until uh,
you know,
I get my job back and that there'll be a lot of truckers in the same situation.
You really think that would happen?
Well I think
the highway for their job back that's less efficient,
kills more people.
So I was with these truckers in the truck stop in Altoona,
Iowa and Joe,
they have really,
really difficult jobs.
I mean,
I don't know if you knew truckers where you were,
but they have this 14 hour window where they're allowed to drive their truck and
they drive most of that.
So they have these other 10 hours and they sleep in their truck.
Two trucks have a bed,
they go into the truck stop,
they take a shower,
you know,
there's a laundry and they're like plugged into this machine of this truck and
the industry,
you know,
they spend days,
sometimes weeks on the road.
A lot of them listened to podcasts.
Probably a lot of them listening right now.
A lot of them listened to podcasts and,
uh,
they're doing it primarily because it's a more lucrative opportunity than the
other jobs that are available to them.
A lot of them have families that like,
you know,
like the supporting their families.
Uh,
and so if you say,
hey guys,
like,
you know,
Time's up for,
for this way of life.
Most of them I think will not like,
uh,
like I actually,
I look at how much they frankly,
they like into your,
there's so much endurance baked into that job that I think most of them will be
like some of the guys you and I know where they're much more likely to like
implode or like,
you know,
do something where,
where it's self destructive than they would be to take their truck,
you know,
park it across the highway.
But you're talking about a population of hundreds of thousands,
including many small business owners and small business owners have a different
mentality very often.
Like,
I've been an entrepreneur,
I'm a serial entrepreneur for the last 20 years.
Like you're an entrepreneur and if you saw this happen,
you might say,
Hey,
I'm adaptable.
I'll figure it out.
Um,
or you might say,
Hey,
I think I can do something about this.
Like if I parked my truck this way,
like that's going to cause such havoc that it's,
you know,
it's like hundreds of millions of dollars worth of economic harm very,
very fast.
And if you look at the industrial revolution,
which people cite as the precursor to what we're going through,
there were mass riots in the industrial revolution that killed dozens of people,
caused billions of dollars worth of damage.
Labor Day's a holiday today because of those riots.
And then we implemented universal high school in 1911 and part as a response to
these riots.
So according to the estimates,
this is called the fourth industrial revolution and we're going to displace jobs
at three to four times the rate of that industrial revolution.
And that industrial revolution included mass riots.
So thinking that this one will not strikes me as really,
really optimistic and perhaps unrealistic.
Hmm.
What do you see coming when,
when you,
when you think that these jobs are going to be automated and then universal
basic income is going to supplement their in,
it's going to give them some money,
$1,000 a month,
but where do they go from there?
I mean,
how do people exist on $12,000 a year?
Like what do they do?
Like how do they adapt to this new world?
Right?
So the first thing you have to do is you have to look at what lies ahead if we
do nothing,
right?
Uh,
so the,
the way it's going to play out is that self driving trucks are slowly going to
start Hamal highways.
Amazon's testing them out right now and the first age is going to be that there
is a human driver just sitting there as a fail safe and the truck's going to
drive itself.
Uh,
now my friends in Silicon Valley are working on tele operators,
which is,
so the trucks have right now,
like a 98% accuracy level,
which is not very high because you can't have 2% semi trucks like running into
things like go,
go,
go the roads.
So,
so the way they're trying to get the last percenter.
So is there equipping trucks with tele operating software,
which means that a trucker,
a tele operator in Nevada or Arizona,
we'll beam into the truck and just be able to see out the front,
like a video game,
uh,
like uh,
let,
you know it's like drone operating,
but instead of the truck and you beam in and then you just steer the truck until
the computers.
Like I got it from here and then you beam out.
That's what they're working on to try and catch that last bit of uncertainty.
Uh,
so the innovations are happening and again,
Joe,
we're talking about $168 billion a year.
Like everything becomes possible when you're looking at that much money.
So in the absence of anyone doing anything,
the robot trucks will start reducing shifts of various truckers.
I would say six to 10 years from now.
And so then there'll be a bunch of reactions.
Now,
trucking firms already have massive shortages.
They can't find enough people.
That's one reason why they're trying to automate this job as fast as they are
because they're literally like,
you know,
they're short like a couple of hundred thousand truckers right now.
And people don't want to go into this field for a variety of reasons.
The main thing being,
it's like extraordinarily brutal on new,
physically very,
very bad for your family life too,
because you're away all the time.
Yeah.
Uh,
something like 88% of truckers have an early marker for chronic disease,
like,
oh,
like substance abuse,
diabetes,
obesity,
high blood pressure or something along those lines.
And now people think that the jobs going to disappear in the next five to 10
years.
You can't get people in.
So if you play out,
what happens when the robot trucks start reducing shifts,
then there'll be people trying to flee the field of trucking.
And then if it becomes really dramatic where the robot start driving,
let's say between western Pennsylvania and Nevada,
and then human beings get in in those states and then take it the rest of the
way because the robots won't be reliable enough to drive an urban areas.
There'll be reliable enough to drive on an interstate or they just have to make
a few decisions.
Uh,
then there'll be a massive depletion of truck driving opportunities.
And then in my mind,
a lot of suicides,
a lot of,
uh,
self destruction.
And I don't say that lightly.
I say that based upon the fact that that's what happened in the manufacturing
workers where if you unpack what happened to the manufacturing workers of
Michigan,
Ohio,
Indiana,
suicide rates spiked to a point where now our life expectancy as a country has
declined for the last three years because of suicide and drug overdoses.
Uh,
it's the first time that's happened since the great flu pandemic of 1918 like,
we are actually coming apart as a country by the numbers.
So what happened to the manufacturer?
It grows will then happen to the truckers,
but at a,
an even more dramatic scale.
So you'll see truckers going home and drinking themselves to death or,
uh,
doing drugs and overdosing or killing themselves.
Uh,
and then eventually there'll be an outbreak of violence because some truckers
will say,
and so killing myself,
how about I go bust up a robot truck?
Uh,
and there are already truckers that are doing things like blocking Tesla
recharging stations and electronic vehicle,
a battery stations because they don't like electronic trucks.
Sure.
Dah.
Those are pickup trucks though.
Those are assholes.
I mean,
this is not like people doing it because they,
they think that these Tesla recharge stations are taking jobs away.
They're just being dickheads.
Exactly.
Joe.
So if you're going to be a dickhead,
even though it really has nothing to do with you,
imagine when you actually think your livelihood is being threatened.
Right.
Good point.
Then you can see it getting revved up,
you know,
to like a much higher level.
Yeah.
So,
so I'm running for president in large part because I think we need to get in
front of this set of problems.
We have to say,
look,
if we're going to save $168 billion a year,
maybe some of that should go to the truckers and give them a soft landing.
Maybe we should have this universal basic income where everyone feels like
they're getting 1000 bucks a month,
which is not a work replacement.
It's not going to make their lives easy.
They still need to work,
but at least it takes the edge off.
It takes like the existential threat off.
Um,
and also their kids getting it.
So they feel like,
okay,
my kid actually has some kind of path to the future.
And it's not like if I lose this trucking job,
not only am I going to,
you know,
struggle and suffer,
but my kid will too.
So,
uh,
my plan as president is to install a trucker.
Transitions are and say,
look,
it is your job to try and manage this transition for the three and a half
million truckers.
And Joe,
we haven't even talked about the 5 million Americans who work at truck stops,
motels,
diners,
retail establishment is all the places where the truckers stop every day just to
get out,
eat a meal.
And you know,
like live a life mean.
If you imagine those communities,
when the trucks don't stop,
there's going to be a drying up of economic vitality on a level that's
unprecedented in many of these communities.
This is something that I,
I'm just becoming aware of over the last year or two.
Um,
how,
when when you were out on the campaign trail and you know,
you're talking to media and you're discussing this with people,
how many people have no idea that this is coming?
Well,
what I say to people,
Joe,
is I say,
Hey,
have you noticed stores closing on your main street?
And then they say yes.
And then I asked them why is that?
And then they reflect for a minute and then they say Amazon.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's right.
It was getting $20 billion of commerce every year and it's now tipping your
malls and main street stories into oblivion.
And like is that going to get better or worse?
Cause so some people say it's like how the robots,
like the robots are years away and then you're like,
no,
it's not robots actually like walking around your neighborhood.
I mean of course that's unlikely.
But Amazon soaking up the business that used to go to your mall,
if you go to their fulfillment center,
it's robots as far as the eye can see if you go to their uh,
their warehouse,
you know,
it's also robots as far as far as the eye can see.
So when you ask how aware are people that this is happening,
it's one of those truths that as soon as you pointed out,
they're like,
oh yeah,
like I,
I knew that was what was up is just for whatever reason,
I'm like the only person just laying out the facts and being like,
guys,
it's not your imagination.
Like we actually are getting rid of the most common jobs in the U s economy
filled by high school graduates and then replacing them with a handful of jobs
for higher skilled people in different places.
And then we're pretending that the first population is somehow going to access
the new opportunities when the odds of them getting up and moving to Seattle or
whatnot and becoming a web designer or like logistics manager or a big data
scientist or something like essentially near zero.
And so this is what gave rise to a lot of the anger that got Donald Trump
elected because they looked around their communities and we're like,
hey,
I used to work in this manufacturing plant.
This manufacturing plant no longer exists for whatever reason.
Like I'm being told that it's somehow like my fault that I wasn't adaptable
enough.
Like I didn't,
you know,
I didn't somehow become a coder or something ridiculous and not to say Joe,
and this is something that I've picked up from Dennis and part.
So I'm with this trucker in Iowa and he says to me,
he says like,
I don't think that Democrats care about people like me.
Uh,
and he says that to me while I'm in his truck and I'm just like,
I can understand why he feels that way.
But that's incredibly destructive because there is a point at which Democratic
Party used to be very,
very heavily aligned with working class Americans.
And there's now some kind of a pathology that if the person who's suffering is a
white man of a certain background,
then the suffering somehow is like somehow like diminished.
Like it doesn't count as much if they're a trucker.
Uh,
and that's something that I find really destructive.
It's like we have to start acknowledging the sources of the problems.
One thing I'm saying to people is like,
look,
it's not immigrants that are taking these jobs away.
Like just facts.
It is not immigrants.
It is the fact that technology is pushing our economy in a direction that makes
it harder and harder for many Americans to get by based upon this current,
I trade my time for money model.
Now truckers seemed to be the big one,
right?
Yeah.
Cashiers are another one.
Um,
what are the other job?
The jobs that are going to be killed by automation.
So the,
the next obvious one is call center workers.
Uh,
of course where there are two and a half million call center worker is still in
the United States.
Generally high school graduates,
they make about $14 an hour.
Now when you and I call a company were like pounding keys trying to get a human
because the AI is so annoying.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like,
Hey,
but you know,
just like gimme gimme a person.
Yeah.
But over the next number of months,
AI is going to become industry indistinguishable from a person.
Yeah.
Like the new Google answering service that comes with the pixel phones.
It's amazing.
Yes.
And so that two and a half million call center population's gonna shrink a ton
because after you get AI software,
that's better than one of them.
You know,
it can be most all of them.
that's not like 5,000 jobs.
That's potentially 500,000 jobs.
I was at a conference of CEOs and I asked how many of them are looking at having
AI replace back office workers like various clerical functions.
Every single hand went up.
There's going to be a lot of
clerical work,
having systems talk to each other that's going to disappear.
And one CIO type of like a major bank said that his estimate was,
adds about 30% of the bank's workers fall into that category.
So you're looking at call center workers,
you're looking at back office workers,
you're looking at insurance brokers.
Insurance is a very highly automateable industry cause it's a lot of information
getting passed back and forth.
Cashiers,
as you said,
truck drivers,
delivery drivers,
Uber drivers.
Uh,
it goes even as far as medical procedures.
There was a recent automated,
a medical procedure where they did surgery on a grape.
Yes.
Yeah.
You see that?
Yeah,
I saw that.
And China's already had just a complete automated dental implantation because
China actually has a real shortage of surgeons.
And so their incentives to try and automate this are very,
very high.
Now the interesting thing here,
Joe,
is that let's say I made a robot surgeon tomorrow that was awesome,
could do better work than a lot of people.
Right now the economic incentives still are not necessarily for everyone to use.
My robot surgeon because the regulations aren't there yet in the u s and so
healthcare is a really interesting one.
Another one that's very clearly going to get taken up by Ai is radiology and
looking at tumors on a film,
because it turns out that AI can see shades of gray that a human eye cannot.
And it can reference millions of films where the most experienced doctor can
probably reference thousands.
And so radiology,
I'll tell you,
medical students are running from radiology as fast as they can because they
know that's gonna get taken up by AI.
Man,
this is such a bleak forecast.
It's very strange when we stop and think about all the different things that
human beings find value in as far as their occupation.
Like,
Hey,
I'm a this,
I'm a that.
This is what I do.
And that the idea that these things are all gonna go away,
it's very,
it's kind of disturbing.
Oh,
it.
And when I was digging into the research show,
it's been happening and it's tearing us apart.
I mean,
I referenced the fact that,
so here's some things that are all taught at halt all time.
Our multi decade highs right now in the United States of America,
suicide,
drug overdoses,
uh,
anxiety and depression,
mental problems,
uh,
financial insecurity,
people being unable to pay their bills,
all of these things are at record highs in one thing I know you've talked about
in the past that I think you'd really find fascinating.
So there's been there,
there've been studies as to what happens to your mind when you can't pay your
bills and,
and when you can't pay your bills,
you're like stressing out.
It's like,
if I pay this,
I can't pay that.
And there's always the time,
money trade off.
It's like,
Oh,
if I spend extra time commuting,
maybe I can say,
well,
a couple of bucks.
Uh,
and so what it does is it actually constrains your bandwidth to a point that
your functional Iq goes down by 13 points or one standard deviation.
So just if you say to someone,
Hey,
here's a bill you can't pay.
And then you give them an Iq test it,
their score actually goes down by 13 points a lot.
That's like a really huge effect.
And so what we're doing right now,
Joe,
is we're actually making our population less rational,
less reasonable,
more impulsive,
more subject to bad ideas,
Nastier,
more subject to things like racism and misogyny too,
because it turns out what happens with most of us is you need executive
functioning to resist like racist and massage,
misogynistic impulses.
And so if I make you cash strapped and make it so you can't pay your bills,
you're actually more likely to be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Like,
yeah,
like blame them.
So what you're,
what we're talking about,
again,
it's not this speculative future,
it's that we've been doing this for years and it's actually pushing our
population into a mindset of scarcity of nastiness.
And that's why universal basic income is so crucial because it gets the boot off
of people's throats and it replaces the mindset of scarcity with a mindset of
abundance and rationality and optimism and capacity.
Like I'm an entrepreneur.
You're an entrepreneur.
I'll tell you,
very,
very few entrepreneurs start businesses at a scarcity where they're like,
oh,
I can't pay my bills.
I guess I'm not like starting a new company,
you know,
like,
like most of them.
But $1,000 a month isn't even enough money for most people to pay for the rent.
Well,
the great thing is,
again,
this thousand dollars is yours no matter what.
So right now,
let's say you're,
you're doing a normal job.
Um,
so if you make $1 million a year,
he's still got $1,000 a month.
Yes.
Yes you do.
I mean,
it's opt in so you could opt in and take it,
which most Americans would because it's still 1000 bucks a month.
Yeah.
People get greedy.
For sure.
Yeah.
Thousand Dollars to get my nails done.
Yes.
Or give it away.
If they were they,
you know,
they felt like it.
Yeah.
But the,
this,
so those are the things that are at all time highs.
It's like all these negative social indicators here,
things that are at all time,
lows,
getting married,
starting a business,
having a kid,
moving for a new job.
All of those things are at historic lows in the United States of America having
children.
Really?
Yeah.
We're at record low birth rates right now and it's largely because people feel
too strapped to have kids.
I mean,
that's literally where we are.
When you say record low by like what percentage you can look up right now.
Jamie,
I don't know if you want to look this up.
Uh,
but stories have come out over this last year saying that Americans are now at
the lowest rate of childbirth.
That has been the case in decades or ever.
Yeah,
that's a conversation that I have with people whenever they say that a,
they're worried about population.
The population is growing so fast and overpopulate here it goes.
1.8 births per woman,
2016 what does that mean?
So it's dropping from 1970 at a high.
Well,
it seems fairly,
fairly similar from 1980 to today.
That's still,
it's actually if it goes from 1.8 till like uh,
if it goes from even something like 1.9 to 1.8 is like a pretty significant drop
us birth dip to 30 or low fertility rates sink further below replacement level.
And so you think it's about the thought is that this is because of education and
this is because of people are waiting longer to have children and that this is a
byproduct of industrialization and modern world and that the more educated and
affluent people get,
the less likely they are to have children then it's not the same as far as what
everything I've read about it is that it's not a symptom of people doing poorly.
It's a symptom of people doing well.
You know there,
there are definitely cases where Richard countries just have fewer kids and
that's cool because they concentrate on their careers right now the idea,
but the,
the darker part of this Joe,
is that right now if you're a non college educated person in the United States,
the odds of you are ever getting married less than 50% now for the first time
ever.
And then people are having fewer kids.
To play devil's advocate though,
the,
the marriage thing might be people looking at it and go,
God,
my parents got divorced,
my brother got divorced,
everybody else got divorced.
What the fuck am I doing?
There are a lot of good reasons for it.
It's just,
you know,
as a,
as a happily married man myself,
me as well,
I always tell people don't do it.
I tell people don't do it.
It's just,
it's too risky.
Yeah.
So,
so you can look at,
to me,
certainly to me,
me getting married and having kids like an act of like prosperity or optimism,
there are reasons why it's going down otherwise.
But if you look at things like starting a new business,
I mean that being at multi decade lows,
it's like no positive spin on that,
right?
People moving between states is now what?
Multi decade lows people moving for a new job,
multi decade lows like do you think this is the product of automation or it's a
product of a bunch of factors like
Internet but purchasing and marketing and think people buying most of their
goods and clothes and stuff on.
It's a range of factors,
but one of the big problems,
and keep in mind,
I spent seven years helping entrepreneurs grow businesses in 18 cities around
the country.
Between 2011 2017 that was actually my job.
My job was to be the job creator guy.
And so when you go out to these places,
you see that the dynamism is getting sucked up by certain markets to a level
that's unprecedented in our history like that,
that the disparities between Cleveland and San Francisco or Saint Louis and La
are much,
much higher than they've been at any other historical period,
both by the numbers end,
like after you actually go to the places you're like,
wow,
like this is not a flourishing the way that you'd hoped.
Do you feel like an economic Paul revere in a certain sense,
like the robots are coming,
the robots are coming?
I do.
Uh,
it's weird,
man.
The comparison I make is that if the United States economy is like an elephant,
you know,
the parable of like the people like,
blind people touching the elephant.
Um,
so I'm,
I'm an entrepreneur.
I sold a company to a public company that was a national education company is
based in New York.
And what is the parable of blind people touching an elephant?
Uh,
so what happens is a,
they're,
they're like seven blind men and they get asked like,
what does the l,
what does an elephant look like?
And then one of them is touching the trunk and it's like an elephant looks like
a snake and another one's touching his leg and it's like an elephant looks like
a tree trunk.
Uh,
so that's the way most people experience the economy is that they're like
touching a part of the economy and they're like,
this is what it looks like or feels like.
So I've had this really strange set of experiences where I sold,
uh,
a national education company to a public company.
I lived by coastally between New York and San Francisco for the last five years.
I've operated in 18 cities around the country.
I was,
uh,
I was an appointee in the Obama administration in DC.
So I've actually seen the elephant,
if you know what I mean.
Like I holo.
Yeah.
Like I'm,
I'm like hanging out with,
uh,
the tech wizards and Silicon Valley and I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
we can automate these jobs away.
And they're like,
oh yeah,
we're going on.
I made the job.
Like it's,
you know,
so it's,
it's not a mystery and they're not bad people.
It's like,
Hey,
it's my job to like make it.
And if you gave me a choice between making things work better and creating
abundant opportunities for the other people,
I would choose that.
But I do not have that choice.
I have a job to do,
you know,
this is my job.
And what I tell people is like,
whose responsibility then is it to go tell the people,
look,
it's technology.
It's transformed the economy in fundamental ways and we need to make it so that
everyone benefits.
And it's not just that this like hyper concentrated set of winners and then this
like huge army of,
of relative losers and it's the government's job.
But at this point we've given up on our government as anything.
Like it can't really do anything.
And so now it's no one's job.
And so somehow Joe,
it has become my
job and it blows my mind too sometimes.
Now
coming from a place of being a serial entrepreneur to this presidential
candidate has kind of warning people about the upcoming technological apocalypse
as it were.
Um,
how did you make that transition and what w what was your motivation to get
involved in this?
To the point we are actually running for president on this platform.
Yeah.
So uh,
so sell solid company in 2009 and that was the financial crisis.
Like Wall Street had crashed the economy and I had personally taught these kids
who'd worked at Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley and,
and Mckinsey.
And I was like,
man,
we need smart kids to do something other than just head to Wall Street and
Silicon Valley and we need to have them go to Detroit,
St Louis,
Baltimore,
New Orleans,
start businesses.
So I quit my job,
I donated a low six figures to start this new organization.
And then we trained hundreds of entrepreneurs and helped create several thousand
jobs.
So that was like my wholesome give back.
I was like,
Hey,
I'm like the,
you know the guy who just believes in entrepreneurship because just like you,
I freaking love entrepreneurs.
And I was like,
so here's the joke.
I used to tell,
I went to law school,
I was an unhappy lawyer for five months.
Uh,
and so what I tell people is like if you're a clueless,
ambitious 22 year old who came out of college and you say to your parents,
Hey,
I'm going to go to law school,
they're going to say that's great.
It's really easy to find the law school cause they're just there.
You just apply to it and the government will give you $100,000 loan,
no questions asked.
And then if you say to your parents,
Hey,
I want to be an entrepreneur,
your parents will think that's stupid.
It's hard to find and no one's going to give you $100,000 loan.
So we have this huge oversupply of indebted a law school graduates.
And the huge under supply of entrepreneurs was my thinking.
And so I was like,
okay,
how do we fix that?
So I started this organization venture for America to try and fix that.
And so imagine being this guy,
getting medals and awards for helping create jobs around the country and then
realizing that automation is coming like a tidal wave and that your efforts that
you're getting applauded for are really not going to do the trick.
And then Donald Trump wins the election in 2016 and for whatever reason,
in my opinion,
the media is just not being honest about all the economic drivers.
They're blaming racism,
Russia,
Facebook,
the FBI.
And if you look at the voter district data on a district by district basis,
there's a straight line up between the adoption of industrial robots in that
voting district and the movement towards Trump.
Like it's a straight economic story where we blasted away for a million
manufacturing jobs in the swing states and Donald Trump is our president.
So imagine being me and in seeing that and being like,
okay,
I get it.
This is an economic,
technological story.
And then I went to people in Washington DC.
I was like,
hey guys,
what are we going to do?
We're in the third inning of the greatest economic and technological
transformation in the history of our country.
And the inning has brought us Donald Trump,
the fourth,
fifth,
sixth endings are going to be horrific.
What are we going to do?
And then the answers I got were somewhere between disappointing and horrifying,
where if you go to mainstream politicians and you're like,
what are we going to do?
The answers I got were literally number one.
We cannot talk about that.
Number two,
we should study that.
We cannot talk about that.
That was,
that's verbatim really.
Yeah.
And why were they saying that?
Because it seems alarmists like anti progress or like,
you know,
you're like,
uh,
you know,
throwing stones at it like,
like big tech companies and it's like,
I'm not throwing stones at anyone.
I'm just pointing out the fact.
So number one is,
uh,
so number one was,
can't talk about it.
Number two was need to study it.
And the number three was the point you made a originally,
which was we must educate and retrain Americans for the jobs of the future.
And then when I was like,
Hey,
we're terrible at that by the numbers,
then they'd literally be like,
well,
I guess we'll learn to get better at it then.
And then I,
so I came back to my home in New York City and I was like,
oh my gosh,
we are so backward and far gone as a,
as it certainly as a government.
Um,
and so then I was grappling with it and I'm a parent like you are.
And I looked at my kids and I was like,
am I really gonna bring them up in this shit show?
Like is this really that?
Is this really the plan?
And so then I was like,
okay,
how would you actually solve this problem if you,
if you had to do so?
And so then I said,
okay,
universal basic income,
rebranded the freedom dividend after we did a bunch of tests because it tests
much better as the freedom dividend than universal basic income.
And,
and then try and make the,
the rules of the economy work better for more people as fast as we can before
this automation wave really crescendos.
What do you mean by that?
Well,
to me like,
you know what I'm saying is like retail and truck driving are the two major,
major,
obvious sectors that are going to get displaced.
Being a retail worker is the most common job in the United States right now.
The average retail workers,
a 39 year old woman with a high school education making between 11 and $12 an
hour.
So what do those workers do when 30% of the malls and stores close in the next
five years?
You know,
and then truckers are next in line,
you know,
by the five to 10 year mark.
So it was like we have to get our acts together before these populations end up
getting displaced.
And we know Americans don't have a ton of savings to fall back on.
It's not like they'll be like,
oh,
like,
you know,
let me take a month off to like think about that.
That's not the real life situation.
Most Americans live and experience.
So,
so this is all 2017 where I'm like doing the data research and saying like,
okay,
like what's the plan?
And then when I went to various politicians,
I was like,
there is no appetite for making this case.
There's no appetite for anyone even talking about this.
So the only thing I can see that would have a realistic chance of accelerating
meaningful solutions to this automation wave in a five to 10 year timeframe is
if I run for president and I either win,
which is very doable,
I can win,
um,
or I mainstream this set of considerations to a point where other politicians
are willing to tackle something like universal basic income and make it a
reality in that timeframe.
Um,
anyone can win,
right?
I mean it is possible.
I mean there are voters,
people are voting,
but do you really believe that you can win?
Well,
Joe,
I'm going to be running if you wouldn't,
right.
I believe that,
but,
but if you were not,
you
know,
I,
I appreciate the question and I've been very up front the whole time is that if
my ideas and policies become front and center and we get this done,
then if I'm not pressing the United States,
like I'm perfectly happy with that.
Like I'm on the record just being like,
I'm just trying to solve problems.
I'm an entrepreneur trying to solve a problem that said,
uh,
I'm already pulling at 1% nationally.
I'm tied with Kirsten Gillibrand and other national politicians right now as
we're sitting here.
I have no idea.
Do you Kirsten Gillibrand,
she's a senator from New York,
so that was nice to be like an a national politician.
Normal morons like myself are not aware of that.
Like I wouldn't have known that you were running if it wasn't for Sam.
I appreciate that man.
But now,
happily everyone who's a fan of yours,
which is apparently everybody now knows I'm reading.
Um,
but so you're,
you're right that most people have never heard of Andrew Yang and I'm already
pulling at 1% enough for me to make the debates.
Are you running as an independent?
I'm running as a Democrat because the mechanics make it such that that is
necessary for you to be able to actually succeed and win.
But I can go through with you the mechanics and you might enjoy this because I
know you,
you and Sam another sometimes talk politics in presidential politics.
So,
uh,
I'm an operator,
I'm an entrepreneur.
And so you get to and be like,
okay,
what does it take to be president?
So there are two rules to run for president.
One is you have to be 35 years or older check.
And then the second is natural born citizen check only rules.
That's it.
So then you get into the process and you say,
okay,
the first two states to vote Iowa and New Hampshire,
now they're going to be about 20 people running for president as a democrat.
This cycle,
you probably knew that,
right?
So,
uh,
you look at the Iowa Caucus.
Iowa has a population of 3.1 million,
but only 171,000 Iowans participated in the caucus in 2016 because it's on a
very high investment.
Now they changed the rules.
So this year it's going to be closer to like,
let's call it 250,000.
But if you have 20 candidates to finish top three in a field at 20 you probably
need about 40 to 50,000 Iowans to get onboard.
So you say,
Hey,
do do I think I can be present?
The United States,
the threshold question is this,
can I get 40 to 50,000 Iowans on board with the idea that them and their family
members getting $1,000 a month is a good idea that that would actually help
improve their lives?
Well,
I'm sure it would help improve their lives and I'm sure they would agree with
you.
The question is,
what are the other thing?
See,
I don't think most people are aware that this is coming.
And I think you educating people and explaining all these statistics and seeing
the forecast,
particularly from your position as a serial entrepreneur who has a deep
background in business and you have a deep understanding of this,
you're,
you're helping in a tremendous way by educating people.
But I think most people have,
it may be a logically,
but they have different concerns.
So how do you address these other concerns?
Like,
I bet if you polled people,
what are the issues?
What are the issues in this upcoming 2020 presidential race that you know who's
going to beat Donald Trump?
How do you do it?
And this is like on the democratic side,
the idea is like anyone but Trump,
right?
Yeah.
This is,
I mean there would be so happy if fill in the blank Tulsi Gabard you,
whoever on the Republican side,
obviously it's Trump unless someone comes along or he goes to jail,
right?
Those are the two possibilities.
What of the other issues and that you feel that people are really concerned
about that you can perhaps shed some unique light on?
So the,
the three big policy is I'm running on our one the freedom dividend cause a lot
of Americans are seeing their paychecks not keep up with their expenses.
Number two is we need to get healthcare off the backs of businesses and families
and move towards a single payer system.
Medicare for all.
Because as an entrepreneur it makes it harder to hire people.
When you do hire people,
you want to make them contractors and not fulltime employees.
It makes it harder for people to start businesses because they're concerned
about keeping their health care for their families.
So we've got to get health care off the backs of businesses and families and try
and make the economy more dynamic.
And we spent twice as much on healthcare as other countries do to worst results.
Like it's right now we're in like the worst of all worlds.
And the third thing is,
and I referenced my wife when I talk about this,
but my wife was at home with our two boys,
six and three,
one of whom is autistic.
And when I say is like,
what is her work valued at in GDP?
And then people think about it and they're like,
I don't know.
And then like zero as GDP,
like doesn't consider that actual economic contribution.
Uh,
and then I say we,
we have to do is we have to actually evolve from GDP as a measuring stick
because it actually doesn't work for us.
It's almost a hundred years old.
We made it up during the Great Depression.
Self driving trucks are going to drive GDP way up,
but it's going to be very,
very bad for many people and communities.
So we have to actually change the measuring sticks to something that would
actually make our economy work for us,
make,
make it so that the market serves us instead of all us being inputs to the
market.
Because if we're all inputs in the market,
we lose to robots and AI [inaudible] hands down and it's not like it doesn't
matter if you were like a really conscientious,
hardworking truck driver or like a really lazy,
sloppy one.
It doesn't matter.
Like you know,
it matter if you were like a really
diligent radiologist or like,
uh,
it doesn't matter.
So we have to shift the market's emphasis to actually fuel our wellbeing and
change from GDP,
which is again,
this archaic measurement we made up to,
to things that would actually correspond to how we're doing things like health,
how childhood success rates,
environmental quantify,
how do you,
how would you quantify that in a way that would be translatable to the average
voter?
Yeah,
so we have measurements for most of these things.
And again,
if you look at our numbers right now,
you'd see,
it's like,
what?
Like how many people listening to this know that America is life expectancy is
declined for the last three years.
You know,
that to me would be like a pretty important measurement.
Is it cause as suicide?
Is it because of drug overdose it because of obesity diet?
What is it?
The,
the two causes that people point to the most are that drug overdoses and
suicides have overtaken be [inaudible] deaths as,
as the most frequent deaths in the United States.
I didn't know that suicide was on that list.
I knew that drug overdose said,
taken obesity with suicides of o overtaken obesity as well.
Suicides of overtaken,
uh,
car accidents.
I'm not sure about it.
I'm sorry.
I meant
I'm at car accidents.
I misspoke.
So car accidents used to be number one.
Yeah.
Suicides are higher than car accidents now.
So suicides,
drug overdoses,
and then car accidents or suicides and drug overdoses.
I think drug overdose and number one,
number one,
and then suicides,
number two.
Wow.
Uh,
and so that's why life expectancy has declined for the last,
you think that the suit and very much likely,
there's at least some of the number of the suicides are related to economic
disparity.
Oh,
yeah.
I mean,
if you look at the suicide rate in it's particularly pronounced in 50 to 50 year
old,
50 to 54 year old white Americans,
which are the population that,
I mean,
you resemble that.
That's me.
Yeah.
That's you,
which resembles the population that right now is as reaching a point where
they're like,
hey,
my job skills don't have any,
uh,
you know,
like utility,
uh,
in the marketplace.
And then they go home and they just like,
you know,
start looking around and being like,
what am I doing?
I mean,
it's,
it's really dark.
It's punitive,
it's punishing.
And we've put our citizens in this situation where we all see ourselves as
economic inputs,
what the market says we're worth is what we're worth.
And if we're worth less than it's our fault.
And so the next move is to say,
okay,
I guess you know this place.
Uh,
there's no place for me here.
I don't mean to sound skeptical,
but I just don't believe that $1,000 in a month is going to fix that.
It seems like that would be a good thing.
Certainly not moving in the wrong direction,
certainly moving in the right direction,
but it seems that there needs to be some sort of a massive rethinking of
civilization itself.
If you're going to have that many things that are going to be automated and that
people,
they're going to be out of jobs and feeling that the world that they prepared
for no longer exists.
Yes.
It seems like we need a step further,
another move a hundred percent brother.
And that's one reason why the freedom dividends not like,
uh,
like,
it doesn't solve the problem.
Right?
The problem is fundamentally one of reconstituting means of structure,
purpose and fulfillment in people's lives,
particularly in men's lives.
How do we do that?
Right?
So one important aspect of that is to actually start measuring how we are doing
as a society.
And saying that's actually where we're trying to go.
So instead of using GDP,
using some sort of other quantifiable method of measuring health and happiness
and fulfillment,
yes,
levels of engagement with work,
uh,
in mental health,
I mean you can,
we have measurements for that.
We are sophisticated enough to do that.
And then if we say,
then as president,
I'm going to be up there in 2021 being like,
Oh,
here's the state of the Union and here's like the data and then we're going to
say,
you don't want to try and do,
we're actually going to try and move those measurements in the right direction.
So let's try and get drug overdoses down by 50% in two years.
Let's try and get our mental health up a little bit like in,
in these ways and then make it so that that person who was at home being like,
okay,
like,
you know,
like there's not a job for me.
I'm getting 1000 bucks a month.
That does not solve all my problems.
It takes the edge off,
but then we can hopefully start re constituting what that person's,
uh,
purpose is in their community,
in their neighborhood.
And so one of the things that I'm going to point out is that if you pump 1000
bucks a month into that neighborhood,
it ends up creating a whole new rung of opportunities for the people in that
community.
Like some of that money goes to,
you know,
like youth leagues and churches and nonprofits,
uh,
and creates jobs right there in that community.
One of the examples I use is like if you're in a town in Missouri with 50,000
people,
and let's say you really like to bake,
but starting a bakery is a dumb idea because people just do not have money in
that town to buy your baked goods.
But then I pumped $60 million a year into that economy and a lot of that just
circulates right there in that town.
Then if I start a bakery,
it's a good idea.
And I know if my bakery fails,
I'm not going to die.
I can at least go home and get my dividend.
And then if I go to other people and say,
hey,
you want to like help me out with this?
And then they also think it's a better idea than they would have.
So the money is not the solution.
The money helps set the stage for the solutions.
So does the measurements.
So it is if you,
cause right now if like you don't even know that your life expectancy is
declining and it's kind of hard to solve that problem.
So if you say,
look,
this is actually how we measure how we're doing.
And then you go in and say okay like local government,
Ngo,
entrepreneur cause right now like our entrepreneurs don't,
none of our entrepreneurs are working on trying to make that dude's life better
right now.
You know,
it's like that that's not only do so much.
Most entrepreneurs are just trying to succeed.
I mean it's very difficult to start a business,
right?
And then they actually have it work out.
Well,
the idea that they're going to look out for truck drivers,
it's not realistic,
but it at least we can start moving ourselves in that general direction if we
start.
Because as a CEO,
you know this,
you make what you measure,
you're not measuring it,
you have no chance.
Right?
If you start measuring it,
you at least start to open up the chance.
But what you're saying is the most profound,
which is like we need to reconstitute and meaning for many,
many Americans.
And that's what,
to me,
the most destructive aspect of that.
You know,
again,
like the,
the mental health indicators and like the suicides and the rest of it is like
there's a real loss of meaning.
Uh,
for many,
many people here in this country,
well obviously we're talking about a large scale,
but if you go back to the time before trucks and truck drivers,
that was not a viable occupation.
It wasn't something people did,
but yet they still found a way to occupy their time.
Do you think that there needs to be some sort of an education and some,
some sort of a,
a method of explaining to young people in particular that you have to think of
something to do because most of the things that you think you can do won't
exist.
So we have to think of what are the other possibilities and be creative and do
something with your life that only a human being can do.
Which is a really weird way to think about it because most of the things you
used to be able to thank that a human being could do for a living are now going
to be done by robots.
But I don't think,
I think there's a giant gap between the understanding that you have and the
understanding that the average person has and this could be a real problem and
trying to expand this platform.
Well,
we have to,
to inform him.
I got to tell you though,
Joe,
when I say this to people,
they're like,
that makes perfect.
So that does make perfect sense.
That's what scary about it.
But I'm not,
I'm not disagreeing with you in any way,
shape or form.
I'm,
I'm just thinking man,
for young kids,
for young kids and you know,
you're a parent.
I'm a parent.
But what,
so our education system,
um,
has a lot to be desired.
And one of the things I'm saying is like,
uh,
is it's making all these kids think that college is the end all be all and it is
not.
And so that's one issue is that,
uh,
we need to try and prepare kids for different kinds of paths instead of saying
college,
College,
because they're going to college,
they're getting loaded up with record levels of debt.
College has gone two and a half times more expensive,
even though it has not gone two and a half times better.
Uh,
and the reason why it's gotten so expensive is because they've just gotten
really bloated administratively.
And what would you do about that?
Like,
you know,
Bernie Sanders wants to have some sort of a free college free university.
Yeah.
They,
the,
he wants to do it across the board,
have education to be 100% free.
I mean,
look,
I love that on paper I,
one of the things that I hate is talking to my friends about college debt.
You know friends that are in their thirties and forties is this following them
around?
Yeah,
it just,
it just stays with them like a wet blanket that you can never get out of.
I used to call my school loans,
my mistress,
cause I was writing a check to like another family and another town.
I was like,
I hope they're enjoying themselves.
It's like I think like $900 above to buy loans.
And what's crazy is that if something devastating happens to you and any other
form you can file for bankruptcy,
but you never escape your student loans no matter what happens to you.
That was just some lobbying on the part of the,
the financial companies,
man,
there's a lot of the crap out of it that is dirty,
that's really dirty.
When you think about how many people that run corporations that have racked up,
I mean just think about what happened with the savings and loan crisis lately,
man.
And those guys skated.
Woo.
The vast majority have,
they're carrying around zero,
zero burden from that.
The vast majority,
no one went to jail step.
A few people in a really anybody real criminals like Bernie Madoff went to jail.
You know,
a few people went to jail.
But that's about it.
You know,
you'd have to be a real fucking thief to go to jail.
And these people that just,
they did this and got away with it and profited and redistributed all this money
into their own personal accounts and,
and stop the whole economy sideways.
But heaven forbid you take out a bunch of school loans and then things go south.
Like you can't get out of it.
I mean,
I know a guy who's in his fifties who's an ophthalmologist,
who's a deeply in debt still.
So amazing.
Yeah,
it is crazy.
And if you look at it just economically,
it's a massive burden on people starting businesses,
starting families,
buying homes instead of hospital with their parents.
Is it possible?
It's possible to fix for sure.
So the first thing you do is you go to the people that are currently in a debt
and say,
look,
we're going to give you a path out and there are ways to do it.
Uh,
you know,
you can have a payment plan.
One of the things I'm proposing it as like a 10 by 10 where if you commit 10% of
your wages for 10 years and you're debt free,
and that means like if you're not making a lot of money,
then you can save a whole lot.
And the schools at this point have long since forgotten about this,
these loans,
cause they got paid off already.
This is just these financial companies that are holding the loans.
That's important for people to understand because people think,
well if you don't pay them in,
the colleges are going to go away.
No,
no.
So if you're the government,
you can be like,
hey loan loan company.
Guess what?
Good News.
We're to like take this out.
It's a stimulus because like you said,
we've done a lot of things that we're supposed to be a stimulus,
like give $4 trillion to the banks and be like,
that'll stimulate the economy.
Nothing's going to stimulate the economy better than getting student loans off
the backs of freaking young people because they'll actually do what they're
supposed to do,
which is I actually spend money,
the economy take chances to take chances and start businesses.
And the rest of it,
I mean,
one of the reasons why our business formation rates are at multi decade lows
that we are up to one point $5 trillion in school debt.
It's like 38 k ahead.
That was like a hundred billion in like 1999 so we've like gone up 15 x since
then and it's crippling us.
It's like insane.
Anyone who thinks that that's not burdening the economy,
I mean you just got to so,
so president Yang will be like,
hey guys,
it's a stimulus,
but this time it's a stimulus that people were going to forgive some of the
student loan debt because half that stuff was generated immorally morally.
Anyway,
a lot of it was just schools,
you know,
lying about it.
Does it get people in the door?
The second thing you do is you go to the schools and say,
hey guys,
why aren't you two and a half times more expensive than you used to be?
That's kind of weird cause like as far as I can tell,
there's been no massive quality change and the reason is that they've hired a
lot of administrators.
It has not gone to faculty.
It has not gone to facilities.
It has gone to just administrative access and bloat and then say,
okay,
you can do whatever you want,
but if you want access to federal loans,
which they all rely upon for their life's blood,
like without it,
they die.
If you want your students have access to federal loans,
you have to bring your administrator to student ratio in line with what it was
like in the 1990s and then the schools would scream bloody murder.
They'd be like,
I can't do that.
That's impossible.
And you'd be like,
well,
I have a feeling you're going to figure it out,
that they,
they would start bringing it down and you would realize it doesn't impact the
student experience at all.
Like I understand it because I've run a large nonprofit organization that I had
started and your very natural tendency is just to hire excellent people.
And then before you know it,
you're like,
have excellent people,
like,
you know,
vice deans of everything.
But then over time that ends up building a very large cost structure,
uh,
that gets passed along to the public.
So you'd bring the costs down.
Now you've said before,
Bernie's like free college for everyone.
The problem with that solution is it pretends that college solves the employment
problems of young people.
And anyone who's coming out of college knows that that's not real.
The underemployment rate for recent college graduates today,
it's 44%.
So you have like a 50,
50 shot if you come out of college or doing a job,
it doesn't really require a degree and 94% of new jobs created right now our gig
temporary or contract or jobs that don't have real paths forward or health care
benefits of the rest of it.
Yeah.
I was reading something,
something
about,
um,
people actually it might've been in that a book that I was just telling you
about Yuval Noah Harari.
Yeah.
21st century and yeah,
it was,
I would say that guy's name wrong.
It's a tricky name.
You evolve Noah Herati yeah.
Uh,
21 lessons for 21st century.
I think he was talking about how many people plan on not being in the same job
in 10 years because that job won't exist anymore versus what it used to be used
to be.
The people would think that they were going to get a job and they would stay
with that job.
Yeah,
I know.
And now they're planning that they're going to have to move,
that they're not going to be able to keep the job.
And as automation kicks in,
this is obviously going to bottleneck.
It's gonna get even,
it's going to give him worse.
Yeah,
yeah,
completely.
So the ideal is that you end up training young people to be really,
really adaptable and have low cost structures and just be able to,
you know,
become entrepreneurs.
And I spent seven years trying to train young people to do just that.
But one of the things I've discovered is that we're over emphasizing college and
what were under emphasizing his technical vocational and apprenticeship work.
Because a lot of that work,
believe it or not,
it's actually really hard to automate.
Like uh,
you know,
we're not going to automate an air conditioning repair person or plumber anytime
soon and for sure craftsmen,
people who build things and as good for your mental health.
Yeah.
And a bunch of other things.
So right now,
only 6% of American high school students are in technical or vocational training
in Germany.
That's 59%.
Give you a sense of what the,
the gap can be to what we're doing is we're overprescribing college were saying
college,
College,
college for everyone.
It's not really working that well and then we're still treating people who are
working in trades and everything is somehow uh,
you know,
like not in great careers when a lot of those careers are actually really
awesome and they pay great and that people enjoy them.
They're persistent.
So right now we're going to automate away.
It's a lot easier to automate away a lot of repetitive cognitive work than it is
a non repetitive manual work because like actual robot digits,
you know,
it's like if you can imagine what it would take to have a robot plumber like
coming to your house,
I mean that stuff's really,
really tricky and there's a lot of fine motor work.
They have to like unscrew pipes and like stuff that stuff's not going to get
automated for a long time.
You know what is going to get automated?
A lot of like entry level cognitive tasks because a lot of journalism tasks,
a lot of bookkeeping and a lot of stuff that college graduates think they're
going to get a job in and then those jobs are going to disappear.
I was a corporate attorney for those five unhappy months and my friends are
working on
AI that can automate away a lot of basic legal work,
you know,
so these colleges,
these college grads,
they're like,
oh snap,
don't know what to do man.
I'll go to law school.
Didn't like load up with another 120 k in debt and then like the,
the legal jobs are not going to be there for him.
It's often the problem of the parents giving them pressure to go into college as
well because they didn't want the kid to become a loser.
And if the kid,
you know like where I grew up in Boston,
if you went into the trades,
if you abandoned like the idea of higher learning,
going to college and just went right into like learning to be a carpenter or
something like that.
People look at you like,
ah,
he's sold yourself short.
But there's so many people that I know that went to school that just got
university degrees and then they got out and they were fucked.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's so common.
It's so common that they thought that there was going to be this path and this
path to sit and exist.
Once they got out or it was,
it was far,
far more difficult than it was then.
They were led to believe.
Yeah.
If you look at it,
about 32% of Americans graduated from college right now and that level has been
more or less constant for a long time.
It's not like,
Hey,
I've another 20% I could get into college.
Like right now the college completion rate in six years,
about 59% so like four out of 10 people who start college are not graduating in
six years and a lot of them are just not going to finish ever.
So like the people that have other pads available,
then we have to build those paths up.
And this is one reason why I'm so into the freedom dividend instead of something
like free college cause why would you subsidize something that only the top
third of the population is going to use?
You know,
an end.
It's a highly inefficient costly system anyway.
Like counting money into that.
You're much better off putting a thousand bucks a month to every 18 year olds
hands.
Didn't they go to college?
Great colleges partially paid for.
They go to trade school,
great trade schools partially paid for.
They start their own business,
they do something creative,
like they want to do something to help.
That's great too.
Like you can actually start building more varied paths and make it so that
people don't feel like I need to get into this institution or else my life's
going to be over.
Now.
What are the primary concerns that people have outside of what you're talking
about so far with automation,
taking away jobs and,
and you know,
student loan debt and these things.
What are the other things that you think you're going to have to talk about in
order to get people to take you really seriously?
I know a,
I mean,
the hot button issues,
you know what they all are,
it's like immigration and climate change is a really big one.
Uh,
and you know,
I mean,
I can talk about those,
uh,
at length.
Um,
so my,
my father and mother met as immigrants from Taiwan at UC Berkeley.
My father is a phd in physics.
He generated 69 us patents for GE and IBM over his career.
So I'd like immigrants are awesome immigrants come in and you know,
it's like big stuff happen for big American companies.
Uh,
so I'm very pro immigrant and I think people would expect that just to look at
me.
Um,
and so what I say is first it makes no sense to educate international students
and US universities and then send them home to compete against us.
That makes no sense.
Like if they're going to come to the US and study,
we should just staple a green card to the diploma and be like,
Hey,
you got a diploma,
great news.
You can stay here and work.
Because I personally know tons of awesome internationals who would definitely
help make the US more dynamic and competitive that go home and start the
companies there and you're like,
oh no.
Like how that happens.
Uh,
that's great for people come from a privileged background who has the
opportunity to come here and become educated.
But what about people who are poor or trying to make it here from South America
owns want Amala there are three paths available to you for the approximately 12
million people who are here,
undocumented,
many of whom from Mexico and Latin America would not like the,
you know,
frankly,
like they're not,
um,
the profile I just described for the most part.
So there are three approaches.
Number one is you can pretend to deport them because it's completely unfeasible
to deport 12 million people.
I mean like whole regional economies would collapse.
Like you can't do it practically.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
Right?
Um,
number two is you do nothing,
which is our current paths.
And then you have massive problems too cause they're constantly interacting with
your schools and your hospitals and they're getting into car accidents and like,
you know,
it's like just not knowing who the heck is,
who is an untenable situation for any advanced society.
So number three is you create a pathway to citizenship and then you integrate
them into society.
But it's like a long term path that takes a number of years and you need to keep
your nose clean and pay taxes and work hard and do most to be the most feasible.
Yeah.
And so that's where we should go.
And some Republicans were on board with that until they paid a political price
and then they ran the other direction.
So that is really the right path for people who are here undocumented.
But I say to people a lot,
but the opposite of Donald Trump is an Asian guy who likes math.
So Donald Trump's like build a wall.
And I'm like,
look,
like,
I mean I'm,
I'm,
we got enforced the a strong border,
like especially in a world where everyone every is getting 1000 bucks a month.
Like you got enforced it strong border.
But at the same time,
you know,
like people who are here,
they're making our communities a lot more entrepreneurial and dynamic.
Many of them mean at the high end,
half of the Silicon Valley entrepreneurs are either immigrants or children of
immigrants.
Um,
and that's true,
uh,
in a different way in terms of like the dynamism of these immigrant communities.
So what I say to people is like,
if I'm president,
people will see that you come to this country,
you work hard,
you're a son or daughter can become president United States.
Now what do you do though in this scenario that you just described?
If someone comes here and they don't work hard and they don't keep their nose
clean and they are still here and they're not a citizen yet.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
so then,
then they operate in the informal economy and the way that they have ended,
the truth is that even if we have this pathway,
they're going to be a significant proportion of people who just do not trust us
enough to say,
Hey,
I'll be here.
I to like enter the pipeline.
There's gotta be a lot of,
uh,
they're gonna be a lot of people that,
um,
don't subscribe.
But that's where it is right now.
We're not making this situation actively worse.
We can at least improve the situation for a really significant proportion of
them.
Yeah.
For a significant proportion of them.
And you know,
the other situation would be tax revenue.
How many people that are here illegally or not paying taxes.
I would imagine it's a,
an enormous number.
Yeah.
There'd be a real economic boost if we can integrate them into the formal
economy because there's a lot of just cash going back and forth.
Right.
And that's what I'm saying is that a lot of people might decide,
hey,
you know what,
I don't even want to be a citizen because of I'm a citizen and I have to pay
taxes or I could work as a laborer or work as a,
you know,
on construction sites or whatever.
Whoever's willing to hire them and work for free.
Yes.
Work rather with a free taxes.
Yeah.
And yeah,
and so I mean that that would still be going on like that.
There are limits to,
you know,
like what sort of appeal you can have in terms of having people raise their
hand,
have a path to real prosperity,
have a real path to citizenship
would be very nice.
And it'd be enormous for them.
Cause a lot of them have kids and a lot of them kids who don't know no other
life but,
but here.
So another issue I think you'll like that comes up on the campaign trail is what
to do about marijuana.
And I'm for full legalization,
remove it from the federal controlled substance list.
And I would go a step further and pardon everyone who's in jail for a low level
nonviolent drug offense because it makes no sense to me to have people behind
bars for things that are legal in parts of the country.
So my plan as president is on April 20th of 2021 I'm going to mass pardon in
everyone who's in jail for nonviolent drug related offense.
I'm going to high five them on the way out and I'm gonna be a very popular man
that day.
Going to be a lot of travel and the high five,
all those folks,
I know I'm going to have to go to a lot of places and high five but I really
want to high five them generally.
Yeah,
I mean that would be the funnest freaking occasion.
Uh,
so,
you know,
that's something that comes up that to me it's obvious that marijuana,
um,
you know,
is an important,
uh,
remedy for many people who are like in,
in various,
um,
uh,
struggling with various like health problems and everything else.
I have friends who were in that situation,
um,
and that it's certainly much less dangerous than,
for example,
some of the opiates that have been getting prescribed for the same same things.
Yeah.
What do you do about that?
That's a question that I have because,
um,
I was just reading something about some new approved drug that's more powerful
than fentanyl,
which seems to me to be completely insane.
Like we already have fentanyl and you just,
you,
you make a mistake on what,
you know,
one of the things that happens with people that overdose is especially old
people that are in pain when they're using fentanyl or using any kind of opiate
on a regular basis.
They sometimes forget if they took it and,
you know,
look,
it's a fucking opion.
I mean those,
they're very powerful.
And if you're high on that stuff and you forget whether or not you took it and
you go and take it again,
you're dead.
Yes.
And that,
that's a giant issue there too.
Damn powerful.
And the idea that you need something that's more powerful than that seems to be
insane.
I agree with you.
It's,
it's irresponsible.
The entire opiate crisis was generated in part by the fact that the feds let
Purdue Pharma just go crazy prescribing hundreds of thousands of oxycontin
prescriptions and that company,
that company got fined 635 million would sounds like a lot until you realize
they made like 16 billion.
So,
and those drop in the bucket.
Yeah.
So those,
those people are now some of the richest people in the country on the backs of
American communities.
And it just keeps morphing.
Cause I went from oxy to heroin defense,
Anil,
and then you have people who are struggling with this addiction.
So to me,
uh,
to me it was federal negligence that I'll unleashed this plague.
I mean you got to hold the Sadler's and Purdue Pharma accountable.
Cause literally now they're profiting from one of the treatment drugs.
It's really obscene what they're doing.
And they're just like,
hey,
my non addictive wonder drug turns out it caused a super plague of lethal
addiction for a hundreds of thousands of Americans.
But now I'm going to sell you a new drug and you know,
try and make money on the backend too.
So you've got to get as much money as we possibly can from that family in
particular.
Uh,
but then you have to make resources available and try and get people to,
to depend on these drugs.
Less like on the front end from the doctor end.
It's just like,
look,
why are you prescribing like the these opiates when like was a doctor I quoted
in my book where he's like you have never seen a lethality rate for something
prescribed for like a non life threatening condition.
It's like literally like a nontrivial percentage of people you prescribe an
opiate to.
We'll be dead in five years.
And the thing that came to you and you know in the hospital wasn't life
threatening.
It makes no sense.
It's crazy.
So we have to make treatment resources available.
But this is a very human problem.
It's not a money problem.
Like you know,
you can throw money at some problems and it works.
This thing we should throw money at to try and give people a fighting chance,
but then you have to support the people coming out cause it's a brutal,
brutal process trying to uh,
become whole and healthy if you're an addict.
It is an unbelievably brutal process and it's,
I have family members that are affected by it and people with hurt backs that
got on these pills and next thing you know,
they can't get off of them.
And it's just,
it's devastating and it's so common.
It's just all through our country and to everyone,
no prescribing you for nothing.
I hadn't my nose fixed.
I had a deviated septum and uh,
the doctor prescribed me two different kinds of opiates and I said,
I'm not in any pain.
And he said,
uh,
yeah,
but you could be so here.
And I'm like,
but I don't think this is a good idea.
I'm like,
I don't even want anything.
He goes,
well,
just take these just in case I'm on to tell you I'm not playing tough guy.
It just didn't hurt.
Yeah,
it was a little annoying.
It was like,
oh my nose feels weird,
but I didn't need fucking opiates.
Seriously man.
They're just willing like here you go,
come on.
What are you in pain?
You Go,
come on,
take a little of this,
take a little of that.
Yeah.
And I,
I have a guarantee for you that their incentives drive them more towards
dispensing those dragons.
The did not expensive.
Those drugs.
Yes.
And it's in large part because the incentive structure of our healthcare system
is so,
uh,
revenue oriented.
Yes.
It's like if I do more stuff,
but by give you more stuff,
I make more money.
If I decide you don't need it,
I make less money.
And that is one of the things that's driving us all into this,
this unhealth is that if you went to a doctor who legitimately was like,
you know,
I don't think you need this,
stuff like that.
That would be the way many of them would see the problem if their paycheck was
unrelated to the amount of activity that they were doing.
Yeah.
Um,
when you look at all the issues that plague this country and you think about the
possibility of you actually winning and becoming president,
and then you look at what happens to presidents when they win and the amount of
just aging happens to them.
Do you worry about that?
Well,
first of all,
Asians age very well.
Yeah.
We've got that going for you
that you know,
and I'm,
I'm married and you know,
we've got two kids so I don't think she's going anywhere.
It can be like kind of tough for her to start over at this point.
Uh,
you know,
I mean one of my,
my nightmare scenarios is I win and then like I can't get stuff done the way
that he goes.
That's the fear.
You've talked about this too where good people go in and government,
he gets stuck like flies and amber because the system is just designed to keep
you from getting anything done.
But one thing I will say is that if you imagine a scenario where the Asian man
who wants to give everyone 1000 bucks a month becomes president,
the United States in 2021 everyone's going to know what how I want.
It will be like,
all right guys,
it's dividend time and then Democrats will be like,
yeah,
I like money for families.
That's great and here's the great thing Joe,
is that then Republicans,
it'll look at it and be like,
wait a minute,
this is a net transfer for rural areas for red states on the interior.
Am I really going to stand in the way that constituents getting this dividend?
And you can imagine me being like,
Hey,
what state wants to pilot this first?
If we can,
every state would be into it.
We can actually get this done.
This is a bipartisan thing.
It's not left or right.
It's forward.
And keep in mind the state that has been demonstrated to love this dividend is
Alaska,
which is a deep red conservative state.
It was a Republican governor that passed the plan in the first place.
He said,
who'd you rather get the oil money?
That government was just going to screw it up or are you the people of Alaska?
And then people will ask about like us please.
It wasn't that 10 cent device people to support the idea of drilling and some
controversial areas.
Though there,
there was probably,
you know,
a whole basket of motivations,
but now that thing has been in effect for 37 years as wildly popular.
So I'm what I'm suggesting when you say like,
Hey,
you become president,
you can't get anything done.
It's like I can get one big thing done because I think it's going to be really
popular among not just uh,
progressive's but also independents.
Libertarians like Milton Friedman who was the patron saint of Libertarian
economists loved this plan because what Libertarians and conservatives hate is
government making people's decisions.
What they like is economic freedom and autonomy.
I just spoke at a libertarian conference like Liberty Khan and was like,
guys like the freedom dividend would help people enjoy actual economic freedom
because you get 1000 bucks a month.
Like,
you know,
that makes you more free to do all sorts of things.
Like you can like,
you know,
you can,
uh,
like make better choices.
Um,
and as long as the government is completely like,
you know,
it's like what you do is your business.
So,
uh,
this can actually become something we can get done.
The freedom dividends a great name too.
It's like the Patriot Act like,
yeah,
man,
excited,
freedom.
We're all about freedom.
Who can be against freedom isn't vote against that.
Yeah.
Who could be against the freedom dividend?
Come on.
What kind of,
uh,
you know,
asphalt do you have to beat?
This is gotta be taking up a tremendous amount of your time.
Like what
are you doing?
Anything else in addition to doing this?
Are you setting aside everything else in your life other than your family
obligations?
I have two jobs,
man.
One,
help accelerate society to try and deal with this historic transition wherein
and to stay married.
Those only things I'm about.
Wow,
that's a,
that's a powerful path.
Um,
now when,
when you're looking at the opposition and you look in all the other people that
are running for president and wonder whether or not they're going to be there by
the time the elections roll around,
what,
what are you saying that's,
it's really interesting,
Joe.
Holy Cow.
That one of the funnest things about running for president is you run into all
the other candidates on the trail in Iowa,
in New Hampshire.
So I'm like just hanging out backstage with like the gang,
right?
It's so interesting and fun.
It is weird sometimes,
but I really liked most of them and so sometimes people will ask me like,
Hey,
who do you want your running mate to be?
And I'm just like,
it really depends upon who I click with best because we're just going to be on
the trail all the time together.
So having met a bunch of them,
I got to say most of the candidates are really genuine patriots who just want to
try and do something positively.
See the country's heading in the wrong direction.
I could work with most all of them.
Uh,
Theresa,
who I think is going to be there in the end.
Man,
it's really interesting.
Uh,
I mean,
one,
one reason I like,
I will say that apparently the mainstream press had it out for Bernie last time
where they were just going to,
like,
I have a friend who worked in the media and they were like,
just like,
you know,
kneecap Bernie
kneecap brain.
Um,
know it's like,
like there's definitely something going on where like certain corporate media
companies have certain candidates,
they kind of want to tip the scales for a little people that they want to like
tip it against.
Well,
they thought that Bernie was gonna get in the way of Hillary winning.
Is that the idea?
Yeah.
I mean they,
they,
they were in the Hillary camp for sure.
Yeah.
And so that wasn't just the media,
that was also the DNC,
which is now on the record.
So now happily,
certainly the DNC has turned a totally different leaf where the DNC is like,
we're not going to do anything that your with Eddie Woods prospects.
Well what they did was a disaster and disaster in terms of public image too.
Yeah.
It was both substantively and like perception was the disaster for them.
So this time I got to say,
and that the team has turned over almost entirely,
like it's almost totally different people.
And then the media,
we have the sense that you know,
they're,
they're still feeling out who they're going to try and put the thumb on the
scale for a Bernie.
Bernie is still running though,
right?
Um,
it looks like he's running it.
You want to know something that's really stupid,
but it changed my opinion of him.
He was being grilled by someone at the airport with a camera and he was
pretending to talk on the phone.
But you could tell he wasn't really on the phone
and I saw that and I was like,
oh,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
You could say,
I'm not giving impromptu interviews.
Thank you very much and keep walking.
Like if you want to interview me,
do it through the correct channels.
But he didn't do that.
He pretended to be on the phone.
It's a weird thing cause if you're willing to do that,
like that's just,
this is deceptive
actually.
If you can actually see the deception,
which I mean clearly you can see the video of the fucking phone is not on,
it's like he's,
it's like you could see his text messages
and he's like in the guy saying to him,
you're not on the phone.
I can tell you're not on the phone.
It's like,
and he keeps walking.
I know that's a stupid thing to,
but it's like,
Huh,
we are,
you know,
we all sass out details about different people in different areas,
you know.
And like,
you know,
it's like,
I think one reason I'm so grateful for this opportunity as,
as like,
you know,
like you actually can get a sense of different people in different environments
and it does end up impacting your,
your perception.
So I mean,
people made decisions on much lesser data points in that,
that way.
I'll remember what the fuck's his name from Vermont who uh,
Howard Dean,
the Dean scream man.
What he's from where he was from Vermont.
Vermont.
Yeah.
That scream killed them.
Sank him.
Do you remember the Chappelle show parody?
The Chappelle show
party of that was hysterical.
It's for me,
but the fact that that it was just because it was a loud,
like a,
as a person who works in front of audiences a lot,
when you're yelling into a microphone,
like the,
the,
you hear like,
especially if you don't have monitors in front of you,
what you hear is like everything.
You hear the crowd screaming,
you hear everything.
And if you're yelling into that microphone,
you're not realizing what it sounds like as a recording with him is like,
and that was it.
One scream.
I imagine,
imagine that one scream literally changed the course of that man's life.
One,
most of them might have changed the course of the nation's history.
Might have crazy.
I don't know if that would happen today.
I think especially post Trump,
one thing that has happened is we're willing to forgive so much more,
you know?
Yeah.
In some ways,
no,
man.
I mean,
I feel like,
you know,
like some,
some people,
uh,
more forgiving than are those for different things.
And for sure there's certainly,
yeah,
it varies.
But it would be interesting to imagine what a,
what the dean scream would result in today.
Hopefully I'm not the person that tested out scream.
Please don't scream.
Um,
so what's next?
Now you,
you,
you're trying to elevate your profile.
You're trying to make people aware of your platform and what you're,
how you're running.
What does next,
it's good fun,
man.
I'm enjoying running for president more than I thought I would.
That's a great thing to hear.
Yeah.
Like it's so one thing is that when you talk to Americans and you know like
rural Iowa or Manchester New Hampshire,
it's like the really good people like you know,
it's like the stuff that you might imagine,
it's like,
oh,
people know.
It's like really good,
honest,
genuine people just trying to make their lives better.
People.
I really love hanging out with our union guys,
like handed the truckers was fun hanging out with,
I hung out with these union metalworkers the other day in New Hampshire.
I was like,
Hey,
I need like,
you know,
robots going on,
you're in your fields.
And then one of them was like,
yeah,
I actually like,
we used to take five to eight guys to bend this rebar to reinforce a bridge.
Now they bring in a robot,
does it overnight and then they're like,
and they're like,
hey,
good for you guys.
You don't have to do this.
And then we're like,
we just lost a free country day's pay.
They were like,
why are we supposed to be happy about this?
So then when I go in,
I talked to them about what's going on in the economy.
They're like,
oh man.
Yeah.
Like yeah,
that's like a real problem.
And unions have been losing for years.
Like they don't know it like the,
you know,
membership's gone and half.
Uh,
so just a on the campaign trail making the case to two different people.
I was on the daily show last week and that's going to fill in pretty soon.
The next big benchmark for the campaign is the Democratic primary debates in
June where they're going to bring all the candidates up.
And this is something the DNC halfly seems like they're being really,
really open about it.
It's not like,
hey,
you need to,
you know,
like,
uh,
like have particular things.
So I'm,
I'm very confident that we'll be on that debate stage and then we can just keep
on making the case to the American people.
When you're going to do something like that.
How do you prepare?
Do you do have someone throw fake questions at you and you practice them and
practice the answers?
Do you work with a coach?
Like,
how does that,
how are you going to do that for that?
Given the enormity of the occasion.
I'm sure we will have something like that,
but I want to double back on a conversation you had recently with a guy named
Lawrence Lessig about campaign finance reform.
And like there are all these interrelated problems in our society.
And in my opinion,
the automation wave is like driving a lot of them because it's making people
less functional,
making people less able to focus on the big problems in the future.
Um,
and then part of it is that our political system is held captive by a rich
corporations and Billy and like mega wealthy individuals.
And like the average voter feels like my vote doesn't matter.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you know,
I was talking to Lawrence Lessig is like,
hey,
how do we fix it?
And I heard your conversation with them.
And so a solution would be,
we give every American adult $100 democracy dollars that can only be contributed
to a political campaign.
And then you end up counterbalancing and washing out a lot of the corporate
money because all of a sudden if I get 10,000 people on board with me,
that's like a freaking million bucks.
Now.
That's very interesting.
That's an interesting idea.
I liked that a lot because the,
the,
the problem Joe was that a lot of our regulatory approaches right now or like
the negative approach,
it's like don't do this,
don't do that.
And the fact is a lot of the time it's really hard to like actually like a
regulate away a lot of this stuff.
And so Lawrence was like,
you know what,
let's just put money into people's hands.
I can only go into the political system and then it makes it,
so if someone like me appeals to humans,
then I get money as opposed to making it so that the people in the money or like
two different sides of the equation.
And I,
I got to say we were talking a,
as a team about being here and like you have like the biggest audience of just
about any media platform in the country right now.
Like bigger than cable news,
bigger than anything.
Oh fuck.
Did that happen?
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
to me you're like a,
you're the primary voice of reason right now in our society,
man.
No one step up and take that please.
I think it's used for the time being brother books.
But what I was saying was that like,
if,
if people that listen to this conversation donate 10 20 bucks to my campaign,
they're like 10 million people are gonna listen to this.
That's like 100 to $200 million.
And that's enough for me to go in and break the,
the,
the moneyed system.
I can go in there and just say,
all right,
let's get money out of politics.
And the way we're going to do it is we're going to actually just give people
money to be able to restore democracy in a real way.
Do you have a patrion page or anything like that?
Um,
my website's Yang 20 twenty.com.
Uh,
and so our average donation is only $19.
So we joke that my fans are even cheaper than Bernie's.
The thing with people is you gotta make it easy,
make it easy,
like having an Amazon one click button.
Oh,
we were taking Venmo for awhile,
so,
you know,
we were like working on it.
It was a bit of a pain in the neck administratively.
Also want to say one other thing.
I did that I think we'll entertain the heck out of you.
Um,
I'm giving 1000 bucks a month to a family in New Hampshire,
uh,
Anna family of Iowa,
just out of my own pocket.
Just to illustrate,
you know,
what $1,000 a month I'll actually like do you and your household?
Good.
And I got clearance with these people.
We had a bunch of submissions a on online for New Hampshire and Iowa.
We're still taking some mission.
So if you know people in Iowa,
they could use 1000 bucks a month,
just go to Yang,
20,
29,
come nominate them and then we'll,
we'll pick someone and there's no obligation.
So it's out of my own pocket.
Uh,
and there's no obligation.
So the FTC was like,
well,
you know,
no problem.
It's just a like an act of philanthropy or like,
you know,
a gift.
And then a family in south Georgia was so touched by my campaign that they're
now is applying 1000 bucks a month to a family in South Carolina,
uh,
in honor of Martin Luther King who was for a basic income.
So we're really inverting this mindset of scarcity and take,
take,
take and being like,
look,
this is like plenty to go around.
We like the richest and most advanced society in the history of the world and
uh,
we can make lives better just by coming together as a people.
There's nothing stopping the majority of citizens in a democracy from voting
ourselves a dividend.
I love the idea,
man.
I really do.
And I love the idea of trying to find solutions to this obvious issue that's
impending.
And then I just seems like we're not going to escape.
I mean it seems like automation is coming.
There's no way to get around it.
No Way.
There's no way around it for sure.
I mean it's here with us already.
It's inevitable.
And the danger we're in right now is that if we don't respond to it,
then there's going to be a lot of,
uh,
a lot of anger about the changes that are coming our way.
And so a bunch of techies are actually supporting my campaign because a lot of
techies are not jerks.
They're just like,
I'm doing my job.
I'm just like,
you know,
my job actually just,
it tends to result and other people losing their jobs.
Right.
And so what I say to them and they agree,
it's like this is enlightened self interest for us all.
It's like progress should be something we're excited about.
There is a world where we're celebrating the fact that the truckers are getting
liberated from their trucks because that's a really difficult punishing job,
especially on their backs.
Yes.
And so the,
the goal is to try and make it so that people are actually able to be happy
about the inevitable.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
it was a quote in my book,
Bismarck was like,
if we're going to go through a revolution,
you'd rather undertake it than undergo it.
You know,
it's like,
like if the revolution is coming,
then we need to get in front of it and start making it work for us instead of
just waiting for it to tear us apart.
Well,
I love the idea and uh,
it'd be amazing if you won.
I mean,
really it would be fascinating.
And like I said,
I've,
I've done a complete one 80 on the idea of universal basic income,
particularly once I started talking to Elon about it when he was saying that
it's inevitable that you're going to need something like that,
that it's coming close on this man.
It's like,
okay,
so if you accept what Ilan said,
that it's inevitable,
which I 100% agree with.
Let's say you go too early.
What is the downside?
Well,
let's see.
You alleviate untold,
pointless human misery and you have more time to build the institutions and help
us adapt.
That's the downside of you go too early.
What's the downside?
If you go too late?
The downside if you go too late is literal disintegration and catastrophe
because it's not like society will magically reorder itself if you're like,
okay guys,
we're a little bit late to this,
but like now we're going to start,
you know like putting checks into people's hands like so the incentive to go
early are pretty much all the incentives.
It's like going to late is literally society ending.
So if you accept what Ilan says,
which I agree with that look,
this is inevitable,
then there's no point in trying to like time it right now.
Put particularly if you accept the fact that all of the signs you would expect
if we were displacing labor already there men leaving the workforce like drug
overdoses,
video games,
like all like it's all right there in front of us.
If you just like take the rock and like flip it over.
And the thing I'm going to say I,
you know,
a friend of mine Andy Stern said,
is that our government is terrible at most things but it is excellent at sending
large numbers of checks to large numbers of people properly and reliably.
We have to lean into one of the only core competencies our government has that
we can trust and then it will let us make our own decisions.
Like this is very much about human empowerment and the alternative is too
terrible to contemplate.
Last question because I guess no discussion of presidential policy and the,
the possibility of someone like you running this countries.
How do you feel about international relations and
the obvious issues of dealing with other countries and what's going on with
China and Russia and the interference of our democracy and all the different
various issues that we've experienced over the last,
particularly over the last couple of years with Russia.
Yeah,
sure.
So about Russia and you and I were talking about this before we went on air.
When I'm president,
I will say,
look,
Russia,
I get it.
We have tampered with other people's elections for years and decades.
Like we in America have done that.
You've done it to us for the last number of years.
It is going to stop right now.
And if we have any credible evidence that you are tampering with our information
and our democracy,
we will take that as an act of hostility and aggression and we will retaliate in
some way that will make your life very,
very painful and inconvenient.
And the people of United States will support me on this.
And so here is your drop dead date,
like turn off the bots.
And if we find that your bots are still going after this date,
I will just bring the evidence,
the American people and then we will act.
And you will not like it one bit.
Now if,
if I mean I'm thinking 80 90% of Americans would get behind that,
it'd be like,
how are we just like looking at it being like,
what are we going to do?
What are we going to do?
And in this one,
I actually feel a little bit for the tech companies because it's very difficult
for the tech companies to,
uh,
to prevent
this.
Almost impossible,
almost impossible,
almost impossible to identify.
And if you go back to Sam Harris podcast,
so we were discussing,
which is called the war of information that I think that's what's called
information war or war of information for a recent podcast in the last couple of
weeks.
Um,
they detail how there's essentially just giant groups of people that work for
the Russian government that pretend to be people that are involved in black
lives matter or pretend to be people that are involved in Texas culture,
southern culture.
And they're just sowing seeds of argument and descent and they are laughing
their asses all laughing and making funny memes.
Like some of their memes are really hilarious,
but,
but to them this is the greatest Roi they've ever seen.
They didn't even like return on investment.
Okay.
Entrepreneur,
Youtube,
man,
I don't have a man hangar.
I haven't normal freaking house.
So,
uh,
like they invested not even that much money like,
but they've found like this underbelly they can just speak in,
slice into and so they,
they've spent best essence,
like low tens of millions of dollars and it's caused us how much damage,
how much harm a real impact in town.
Like you know,
I mean you couldn't even put a dollar figure on it so you have to just say like
look,
I get the tech companies are going to try but they're not going to be able to
pull it off.
So just like go on and just say to like the world and say hey this is to Russia.
But anyone else,
same thing.
Like if you tamper with our democracy,
we are going to come down on you like a ton of bricks and if we're not quite
sure we're still going to come down on you.
Like a ton of bricks.
Like don't need like 100% certainty on this.
I need like,
you know,
like a legal standard.
I need like 80 85% and the American people would be like about time because you
know the,
if we can't trust ourselves or each other or what we're seeing,
and this is before deep fakes and the rest of it starts hitting.
Like if you're actually going to believe in democracy,
then you have to start protecting our information as fast as possible.
And you also in my mind have to start,
and this is a local issue,
but I'm in New Hampshire and Iowa talking about this stuff,
their local newspapers are all dying.
It's like thousands of local papers is winking out of existence because they
used to rely on classified ads.
There are no classified ads anymore.
It's all Craig's list.
And so they all die.
And if you believe in democracy,
how the heck can anyone vote on anything if they have no idea what's going on
right there.
So,
so there are a lot of interrelated issues.
I mean,
one thing I'm saying is like,
look,
we had a happy time where local newspapers were supported by classified ads.
It's over now,
but we're still a democracy.
You still need some information to vote.
So we need to try and find new ways for you to get quality information like
that.
Those thrown our hands up and being,
I guess the Russians are going to,
you know,
like in like just misinform us with bots and I guess all the local newspapers
are going to die.
Like you said,
like these are problems and we have to start solving them.
If you still believe that democracy is the best form of government and that's
what we're going to carry forward with,
would you obviously have to believe,
like you have to go with that as your model.
And so it's all interrelated,
but we have to start thinking much,
much bigger about what we can get done because things are slipping away.
Things are trending in a terrible,
terrible direction.
Well,
Andrew,
good luck to you.
You're a good man.
I wish you well.
Thank you for being here.
I think your message is excellent and I hope you really make an impact.
Thank you Joseph.
Really appreciate it,
man.
President Yang Man,
if I,
if I win,
you can do a special,
uh,
Ari from the White House and that would be a blast.
Let's do it.
Thanks sir.
Appreciate it,
man.